à
jamie merci infiniment merci infiniment
merci pour cet accueil si chaleureux en
effet merci d'être si nombreux ici ce
soir pour partager ensemble cette soirée
est parlé de l'élection européenne qui
nous réunit ensemble et c'est déjà une
chance inouïe que vous soyez si nombreux
c'est déjà un grand signe d'espoir parce
que vous êtes là en dépit de tous les
scénarios qu'on voulait écrit d'avancé
vous êtes là en dépit du fait que ça
fait des mois qu'on vous explique que
cette élection est pliée d'évidence et
que le seul match qui compte c'est le
match entre monsieur macron et madame le
pen entre madame loiseau et monsieur
bardella et bien vous vous avez dit que
vous vouliez avoir le choix que vous
vouliez avoir un autre choix et le fait
que vous ayez pris de votre temps que
vous veniez parfois de loin
que vous veniez de tous les départements
de cette région montre à quel point non
tout n'est pas fait d' avance et
l'essentiel se joue dans les quinze
jours qui commence merci infiniment
d'être ici ce soir
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier en particulier
tout ce qui nous accueillent remercier
la mère de marc qui nous accueillent ici
ce soir et puis bien sûr
chère madame bouchard vous dire merci de
tout coeur pour votre présence pour ce
signe de confiance que vous nous avez
apporté pour les mots que vous venez de
prononcer c'est une immense joie d'être
ici à calais dans cette ville qui est le
coeur de l'europe le coeur de tous les
succès de l'europe et aussi de toutes
ses fragilités et c'est cela que nous
sommes venus partager c'est de cela que
nous sommes venus parler je voudrais
remercier tous les élus qui sont ici les
élus départementaux régionaux municipaux
cher daniel je ne me risquerai pas au
jeu géographique aux politiques
dangereux quelques vies ont été livrés
mais je voudrais leur dire de tout coeur
ma reconnaissance
ma reconnaissance aussi parce que je le
vois depuis le début de cette campagne
ils sont la force de notre famille
politique vous êtes aussi la force de
notre démocratie
cette démocratie elle vit et elle tient
par nos élus locaux par tous ceux qui
sur le terrain tous les jours
réparé le tissu social abîmé rapproche
ce qui est en train de s'éloigner
reconstitue une démocratie que la
défiance menace d'emporter c'est par
vous que notre pays tient et je crois
que nous devons vous dire et nous devons
trouver l'occasion de vous dire ce soir
notre reconnaissance pour tout le
travail que vous faites remercier aussi
nos parlementaires et on peut les
applaudir
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier nos parlementaires
chère brigitte cher sébastien remercier
bien sûr pierre henry pour les mots
qu'il a prononcés
pierre-henri tuer le signe effectivement
que rien n'est jamais perdu d'avancé que
les seules batailles compères sont
celles qu'on n'a pas livré et pierre
henry je voulais te dire à quel point je
te remercie d'être la voix de cette
jeune génération avec d'autres qui
aujourd'hui au parlement font vivre
notre liberté par le caractère toujours
pugnace que tu montres à l'assemblée et
je crois que c'est aussi à travers vos
voix à travers la voix de nos
parlementaires que nous pouvons trouver
encore l'occasion de nous exprimer dans
ce nouveau monde qui se montre parfois
si souvent incapable d'écouter merci de
ce que vous êtes et de ce que vous
faites et enfin je voudrais dire un
immense merci tout particulier à daniel
bien sûr vous me le permettrais parce
que au fond on parle beaucoup de cette
campagne en disant qu'elle fait la
surprise mais si cette campagne
fonctionne c'est parce que beaucoup
travaillent dans l'ombre beaucoup avec
beaucoup d'abnégation ont accepté de
prendre tous les risques de porter
toutes les difficultés
une campagne c'est un engagement de
chaque instant notamment pour faire en
sorte que le nerf de la guerre soit
toujours disponible pour l'action qui
doit être menée et celui qui a accepté
de relever ce défi qui m'a proposé
spontanément alors qu'il est déjà
trésorier de notre famille politique
d'être trésorier de cette campagne c'est
daniel fasquelle et je crois que nous
devons lui dire un immense merci
je lui disais tout à l'heure je lui
disais tout à l'heure mais comment est
ce que tu fais daniel pour être sur tous
les fronts à la fois toujours avec la
même disponibilité toujours avec la même
bienveillance avec la même sérénité
est ce que j'admire infiniment chez toi
c'est ce sens de l'engagement qui te
fait investir autant face au rachat de
siemens par ji que sur la cause de
l'autisme que tu portes avec tant
d'ardeur
je crois que c'est ça qui fait la force
de nos parlementaires c'est ça qui fait
la force de notre famille politique et
c'est ce que tu incarnes ici bien sûr et
je voudrais te dire encore merci et puis
bien sûr dans une équipe comme la nôtre
tu as eu tu as eu des mots bien trop
bienveillants daniel en disant que
j'avais réveiller cette élection je n'ai
pas réveiller cette élection c'est nous
qui l'avons réveillé
c'est nous avec toi laurent c'est nous
avec vous tous ici c'est nous aussi avec
tous nos colistiers et je voudrais leur
dire à quel point je suis heureux et
fier de pouvoir mener cette équipe
allait à à karim à sandrine à gabriella
sébastien et bien sûr tout
particulièrement à faustine faustine
tuer la première avec laquelle nous
ayons créer des liens forts
nous nous sommes parlé plusieurs fois tu
m'a dit ton désir de voir cette terre
que tu représentes portée est représenté
dans cette liste et je crois que les
questions que vous rencontrez ici ces
questions européennes il faut qu'elle
soit en effet porté défendu tout au long
du mandat et je voudrais dire à tous mes
colistiers qui sont ici que cette liste
qui a été constitué par laurent cette
liste il faudrait qu'elles travaillent
ensemble tout au long des prochaines
années d'abord il faut que nous soyons
grâce à vous par votre action le plus
nombreux possible à rentrer demain au
parlement européen mais il faut aussi qu
avec vous tous avec geoffroy nous
puissions continuer de travailler tout
au long des prochaines années élus ou
non pour que cette liste portent
ensemble
l'action du mandat européen tu en feras
parti faustin natacha a eu raison de
dire à quel point c'était en effet
important nous travaillerons tous
ensemble pour porter les couleurs de
notre famille politique pour porter
aussi la diversité de nos territoires
qui doivent être représentés au
parlement européen parce que de fait
parce que le fait nous le savons bien
nous sommes aujourd'hui à la croisée des
chemins
l'europe est à la croisée des chemins et
notre rencontre de ce soir elles se
déroulent dans la joie de nous retrouver
tous unis mais aussi dans la certitude
et la gravité la certitude que nous
avons devant nous un choix décisif à
faire depuis le début de cette campagne
je l'entend partout en france partout où
nous allons
je l'entends monter cette défiance cette
défiance qui a produit le break site
elle existe aussi en france cette
défiance qui fait que tant
d'agriculteurs temps d'entrepreneurs
temps de salariés dans d'ouvriers ont le
sentiment que l'europe nous fragilise au
lieu de nous renforcer
bien sûr nous croyons à l'europe est
notre famille politique est engagée
comme jamais dans le travail européen
parce que nous croyons que l'europe est
plus nécessaire que jamais mais nous
croyons aussi que pour que l'europe
puisse nous renforcer dans la
mondialisation il faut la réorienter en
profondeur il faut refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france et voilà
le projet qui est devant nous et voilà
pourquoi il est nécessaire de rentrer
dans le fond dans les sujets concrets
qui préoccupent les français
il ne suffit pas dans cette élection de
dire qu'on est pour l'europe ou de dire
qu'on est contre l'europe
il ne suffit pas d'être du côté de ceux
qui sont les gentils progressiste ou du
côté de ceux qui sont les méchants
populiste cette politique de posture
cette politique d'idéologie cette
politique d' attitude politicienne
superficielles nous n'en pouvons plus
nous n'en voulons plus elle est en train
de tuer le débat politique et elle est
en train de tuer si nous n'y prenons pas
garde
ce débat européen dont nous avons
tellement besoin nous le voyons bien ils
se sont mis d'accord
[Applaudissements]
ils se sont mis d'accord pour vous voler
cette élection ils se sont mis d'accord
pour qu'on ne parle pas d'europe
ils se sont mis d'accord dans ce moment
pourtant décisif pour l'avenir de la
construction européenne pour qu'on ne
parle que de la question de savoir qui
va l'emporter de monsieur macron ou de
madame le pen est ce que c'est à la
hauteur des sujets est ce que c'est à la
hauteur des enjeux
est-ce que c'est prendre les français au
sérieux que de leur faire croire que
c'est un match à deux qui représenterait
l'état de notre démocratie
si l'on additionne toutes les enquêtes
d'opinion et parfois il faut savoir les
écouter on verra que seuls 20% des
électeurs français qui serait capable de
voter seuls 20% des électeurs français
se reconnaissent de madame le pen ou de
monsieur macron 20%
eh bien nous nous voulons parler aux 80%
restants à ce que 80 % qui ne se sentent
pas représentés à ce 80 % qui sont déjà
dégoûté de ce match qu'on voudrait leur
imposer à ses 80 % de français qui
attendent des réponses concrètes à ceux
auxquels on ne parle plus parce qu'on
veut jouer ce match politiciens qui a si
peu à voir avec la beauté de la
politique monsieur bardella est entré en
campagne en disant j'ai un grand rêve
pour le 26 mai c'est de voir pleurer
christophe castaner on a les rêves qu'on
veut dans la vie
et madame loiseau et rentrer en campagne
en disant mon but dans cette campagne
madame loiseau et rentrer en campagne en
disant mon but dans cette campagne c'est
de battre le rassemblement national
madame le pen dit aujourd'hui notre but
c'est de battre monsieur macron monsieur
macron dit notre but c'est de battre
madame le pen et bien nous nous disons
que notre seul but c'est de résoudre les
problèmes des français
et on ne fera pas on ne fera pas reculer
la défiance qui monte partout simplement
en l'insultant
bien sûr nous ne croyons pas une seule
seconde à une politique qui consisterait
à prospérer sur la colère sans lui
apporter de réponse tu l'as dit pierre
henry nous ne croyons pas non plus à une
politique qui consiste à culpabiliser
ceux qui doutent ceux qui s'inquiètent
ce qu'ils voient partout aujourd'hui les
fragilités de cette europe que nous
avons construite
ils attendent des réponses concrètes et
lorsqu'un agriculteur me regarde les
yeux dans les yeux et me dit aujourd'hui
je travaille comme un fou et je vis
comme un misérable je n'arrive pas à
gagner ma vie malgré la politique
agricole commune et j'ai l'impression
que l'europe ne complique la vie au lieu
de me renforcer
lorsqu'un agriculteur me regarde les
yeux dans les yeux en me disant cette
europe là je n'y crois plus je ne me
sens pas la légitimité la responsabilité
le devoir de le traiter de populiste je
crois que notre devoir c'est lui
apporter des réponses et notre devoir
n'est pas de prospérer sur cette colère
qui monte notre devoir n'est pas non
plus de persévérer dans le déni de
réalité
notre devoir c'est de refonder l'europe
pour pouvoir rétablir la france de
refonder une europe dans laquelle plus
aucun agriculteur ne puisse se sentir
abandonnés une europe dans laquelle plus
aucun entrepreneur né le sentiment que
l'europe lui compliquer la vie au lieu
de le soulager une europe dans laquelle
plus aucun maire ne soient abandonnés
seuls face au poids de la crise
migratoire que nous n'avons pas su gérer
voilà notre devoir voilà ce qu'est la
politique est bien ce devoir là on
voudrait nous en priver cette politique
là on voudrait nous l'a retiré ce débat
si fondamental
on voudrait l'interdire et bien moi je
vous le dis nous allons déjouer les
pronostics et nous allons rendre à la
politique ses lettres de noblesse
et c'est vrai que le disait geoffroy je
suis frustré aujourd'hui de voir que ce
débat n'est pas possible nous avons
devant nous la liste dans marche qui
nous disait que l'europe c'était le
coeur de son projet est bien ce projet
il aura fallu attendre 15 jours avant le
scrutin pour qu'on puisse enfin le
découvrir c'était pour la fête de
l'europe paraît-il c'était le 9 mai on a
beaucoup de chance que la fête de
l'europe soit pas tombé le 27 mai parce
qu'on aurait sans doute pas eu le projet
avant de voter en tous les cas quinze
jours avant le scrutin on a pu enfin
découvrir ce que voulait la république
en marche
on sait enfin à peu près quelles seront
ses alliés mais aujourd'hui nous avons
une tête de liste qui refusent de
débattre qui refusent d'échangés qui
refuse de dialoguer aussi plus
exactement elle n'accepte de dialoguer
qu'avec une seule personne avec monsieur
bardella et bien moi je dis qu'il y a là
un vrai problème démocratique et je
crois qu'on ne peut pas prétendre
sérieusement combattre l'extrême droite
quand on considère l'extrême droite
comme le seul interlocuteur
démocratiques légitimes
moi je dis qu'on ne peut pas prétendre
on ne peut pas prétendre combattre
l'extrême droite quand on fait tout en
réalité pour la faire exister dans le
débat politique
nous avons un but c'est de répondre aux
problèmes des français
c'est de faire en sorte de retirer ce
qui nourrit aujourd'hui cette colère le
problème de l'europe ça n'est pas le
bric site
le problème de l'europe ce n'est pas les
populismes le problème de l'europe c'est
ce qui nourrit le populisme
le problème de l'europe c'est ce qui a
suscité le break site et voilà ce à quoi
il faut s'attaquer
le problème de l'europe c'est cette
naïveté qui a trop longtemps durer sur
le terrain économique et commerciale
cette naïveté qui nous a fragilisés dans
la mondialisation
nous croyons que l'europe est nécessaire
et elle a inventé les outils formidables
qui peuvent nous permettre de garder la
place de nos pays dans le monde qui se
dessine
elle a fait l'euro elle a fait le marché
unique
mais ce marché unique aujourd'hui est
d'abord une proie et une cible au lieu
d'être un levier pour nous renforcer
au lieu d'être un acteur et nous avons
parfois l'impression c'est vrai disons
le dans cette crise que nous vivons
d'être les spectateurs d'un monde qui se
fait à l'extérieur de l'europe dans
l'histoire se joue à l'extérieur de
l'europe alors que nous avons tout pour
pouvoir agir en europe
encore faut-il sortir de cette naïveté
nous avons aujourd'hui en europe encore
la naïveté de croire qu'il suffit de
montrer l'exemple de l'ouverture pour
que tous les pays du monde nous imite le
saviez vous par exemple en union
européenne 20% du pib est représentée
par les marchés publics 20% de la valeur
créée en europe et fait des marchés
publics eh bien ces marchés publics sont
ouverts à 95% aux acteurs internationaux
nous sommes les seuls au monde à être
ouvert ainsi les marchés publics
américains ne sont ouverts qu'à 30%
les marchés publics canadiens à 10% les
marchés publics chinois 0%
comment est il possible qu'une
entreprise chinoise peut venir prendre
un marché public en france et faire du
profit en france alors que jamais une
entreprise française
même la plus compétitive même la plus
exceptionnelle ne pourra prendre un
marché public en chine
cette situation là nous ne pouvons plus
la supporter plus longtemps et nous
devons maintenant exiger de nos
partenaires commerciaux de tous ceux qui
veulent échanger avec nous une stricte
réciprocité
parce que cette réciprocité
cette réciprocité elle est la condition
cette réciprocité est la condition pour
que la compétition est un sens
nous croyons à la compétition nous
croyons à la force de nos entreprises
nous sommes patriotes
nous croyons à l'excellence de nos
savoir-faire est ici dans cette terre
des hauts de france
on sait ce qu'un ouvrier français est
capable de faire ici sur cette terre on
sait ce que nos entreprises sont
capables de produire 11 c'est la force
des savoir faire que nous avons su
transmettre actualisé on sait ce que la
france peut apporter au monde et ce dont
elle peut rayonner dans le monde de
demain
mais pour que la compétition est un sens
il faut que les règles soient les mêmes
pour tous la meilleure équipe du monde
si elle rentre sur un terrain qui n'est
pas plat et dans laquelle l'arbitré ne
jouent pas le jeu
la meilleure équipe du monde perdra
forcément la compétition eh bien nous
sommes dans cette situation nous sommes
la première puissance commerciale au
monde et pourtant toutes les autres
puissances du monde nous dit aujourd'hui
leur loi il faut en finir avec cette
naïveté il faut en finir avec cette
impuissance et il faut assumer enfin que
le premier rôle de l'europe c'est de
défendre d'abord nos entreprises et nos
emplois et je rejoins
je rejoins ici sur ce point ce que vous
disiez à l'instant le premier rôle d'un
maire c'est de défendre son territoire
est bien le premier rôle de l'europe
c'est de défendre les européens il y as
aux etats-unis 1 buy american act ii ne
pouvons pas en vouloir aux américains de
défendre leur entreprise et leur emploi
aux états unis si vous voulez acheter un
bien
vous n'avez le droit de l'acheter sur le
marché international que si vous ne
l'avez pas trouver sur le marché
américain
eh bien pourquoi faudrait-il que nous
nous interdisions d'écrire un bail
européenne actes pourquoi faudrait-il
s'interdire de privilégier d'abord nos
entreprises de privilégier d'abord nos
savoir-faire nos acteurs économiques et
nos emplois pour ne plus subir cette
désindustrialisation qui a si durement
marqué le territoire où nous sommes
évidemment ce ne sont pas ceux qui ont
laissé couler mifare et link qui
pourront nous dire qu'il faut défendre
nos entreprises qu'il faut défendre nos
emplois
c'est la tâche de notre famille
politique et nous opposer à cette
naïveté
ça n'est pas seulement tourné la page
des erreurs du passé
c'est prendre la mesure de notre
responsabilité si nous ne savons pas
faire ses choix
si nous ne savons pas refondé l'europe
si nous ne savons pas faire entendre la
voix de la france en europe
alors c'est vrai le projet européen
risque d'en être durablement discrédité
et il risque de voir poindre de nouveau
la menace de nouveaux breaks site un mot
peut-être sur le bric side car c'est
exactement de cela qu'il s'agit
j'ai été très frappée dans les débats
que nous avons pu avoir où toutes les
listes se retrouver dans ce débat
notamment sur france 2 que vous avez
peut-être eu le courage de regarder je
sais pas si vous avez eu le courage je
vois à vos rires nerveux que certains
ont peut être regardé en effet vrai je
sais pas si vous avez eu le courage de
regarder jusqu'au bout parce que c'était
quand même très long moi j'ai essayé
d'éteindre la télévision mais j'étais
dedans alors j'ai pas pu c'était très
long et parfois un peu confus et je
crois à la force du débat mais justement
c'est pour cette raison qu'il était
peut-être utile d'avoir des dialogues
plus plus personnel avec d'autres têtes
de liste pour clarifier les enjeux
ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé cette
question du bric site c'était de voir le
caractère très idéologique du tour que
la discussion prenait et certains de
dire que les anglais avaient pris la
mauvaise décision d'autres qu'ils
avaient pris la bonne les certains de
dire qu'il fallait qu'il rejoue vote
d'autres qui ne votent pas
nous disons que notre rôle n'est pas là
notre rôle de parlementaire européen
notre rôle de parlementaires français
demain au parlement européen
c'est de défendre par tous les moyens
les intérêts des français et je crois
qu'il ya là un enjeu absolument crucial
nous avons vu lire l'irresponsabilité de
nos concurrents dans cette affaire de
ceux qui effectivement se sont réjouis
du bric sites comme s'il n'aurait pas
d'impact sur les plus vulnérables déjà
de ceux d'entre nous qui subirons
directement ses conséquences les plus
durs l'irresponsabilité aussi disons le
du président de la république qui a été
le seul dans le dernier sommet européen
a affirmé que tout était préférable y
compris une sortie sans accord à la
poursuite des négociations
nous nous disons très clairement que
rien ne serait pire qu'une sortie sans
accord que bien sûr ce feuilleton dure
depuis trop longtemps que bien sûr il
est nécessaire que les britanniques se
mettent d'accord qu'ils sachent se
mettre d'accord comme les européens
l'ont fait sous la conduite de michel
barnier dont le soutien nous honore en
effet sous la conduite de michel barnier
qui a su obtenir à chaque étape de la
discussion
l'unanimité des 27 états européens et
voilà comment l'europe avance il faut
maintenant que les britanniques puissent
répondre à cet accord mais rien ne
serait pire que de conclure cette
discussion est de rompre sans accord
parce que si une sortie sans accord
devait avoir lieu
c'est 50% de la pêche française qui
resteraient à quai c'est à dire des
dizaines de milliers de familles qui
seraient directement impactés un emploi
en mer c'est trois emplois sur terre si
un break site sans accord devait avoir
lieu c'est notre industrie qui serait
directement touchés parce qu'elle a
besoin de ce lien avec la grande
bretagne
c'est le service de sécurité qui ne
pourrais plus travailler ensemble et
c'est donc une fragilité devant la
menace terroriste
une fragilité supplémentaire que nous
aurions à subir si une sortie sans
accord devait avoir lieu
c'est les agriculteurs qui verrait
arrivé soudainement sur le marché
français des dizaines de milliers de
tonnes des centaines de milliers de
tonnes de produits agricoles qui ferait
chuter leurs prix de leur propre
production
déjà durement éprouvé oui il y a quelque
chose d' irresponsable a prôné une
sortie sans accord les nous continuerons
au cours des semaines qui viendront car
cet enjeu est décisif de défendre à tout
prix une issue favorable pour cette
discussion mais tous vaudra mieux qu'une
sortie sans accord est notre seul et
unique but sera de prendre en compte
les intérêts des français et en
particulier des habitants de cette
région et de ce département
sortir de la naïveté pour assumer notre
rôle dans la mondialisation c'est aussi
bien sûr faire face à ce grand défi
migratoire
car c'est seulement par cet équilibre
retrouvé que l'europe pourra offrir au
monde
lorsqu elle redeviendra un poumon dans
la mondialisation pour faire face au
défi environnemental
lorsqu elle acceptera de défendre ses
intérêts qu'elle offrira au monde de
demain cet équilibre qu'il a besoin de
retrouver cet équilibre il faut qu'il
soit aussi maintenu sur la question
migratoire il faut qu'il soit aussi
rétabli face à ce grand défi et ce grand
défi vous l'avez dit il n'est pas
derrière nous il est devant nous la
crise migratoire gabriel elle n'a pas
encore commencé elle n'a pas encore
commencé car le défi de la démographie
du continent africain est immense et il
est devant nous et si nous ne savons pas
maîtriser nos frontières nous allons
continuer de produire du malheur à
grande échelle malheur bien sûr pour nos
sociétés malheur pour nos sociétés déjà
si durement touchée par le poids d'une
immigration massive que nous n'avons pas
su réguler et que nous n'avons pas su
intégrer malheur pour nos sociétés qui
sont directement déstabilisés par ces
flux migratoires incontrôlés et vous
êtes mieux placés que quiconque ici pour
le dire
et pour en témoigner même alors aussi
disons le pour tous ces jeunes venus
d'afrique auquel des passeurs sans
scrupules temps le miroir aux alouettes
d'un eldorado qu'ils ne trouveront pas
s'il arrive en europe
vous l'avez dit chaire natacha nous ne
pouvons pas opposer l'humanité à la
fermeté la première exigence du devoir
d'humanité c'est de maîtriser nos
frontières c'est de maîtriser nos
frontières pour faire en sorte que
soient vraiment accueilli ceux qui ont
besoin de notre aide
mais pour faire en sorte que nous ne
confondons pas ceux qui légitimement
sont éligibles à l'asile et ceux qui
viennent uniquement chercher un espoir
en europe où ils ne trouveront qu'une
impasse à ceux qui nous font de grandes
leçons de morale sur la question
migratoire à ceux qui nous parlent de
générosité et d'accueil
il suffit de leur demander venez porte
de la chapelle
venez dans nos centres villes venez
partout où s'entassent ces jeunes venus
d'afrique qui se retrouvent errant dans
un endroit où
déracinés et sans avenir venez bien sûr
à calais venez voir ce que signifie ce
que vous appelez générosité et qui n'est
que l'autre nom de notre inconséquence
venait à calais voir ce que signifie le
fait de ne pas maîtriser ses frontières
aujourd'hui le président de la
république semble redécouvrir que le
mode frontière n'est pas un mot tabou
c'est une bonne nouvelle je me souviens
d'une époque où quand nicolas sarkozy
parle et frontière on l'accusait d'être
d'extrême droite je pense que ceux qui
prônent le no border ceux qui veulent
supprimer les frontières devraient venir
à calais voir qu'ici on est contraint de
mettre des murs avec des fils de fer
barbelés même autour des stations
service même entre même autour des
entrepôts quand on abolit les frontières
à l'extérieur d'une réalité politique
on les multiplie à l'intérieur d'une
société et ses frontières se multiplient
pour fracturer notre espace commun pour
fracturer notre lien commun nous sommes
contraints de mettre des murs autour de
la tour eiffel
quand on abolit les frontières qu'on ne
sait pas à les maîtriser en réalité on
les multiplie par tous sur un territoire
commun et c'est ce qui est en train de
nous arriver aujourd'hui nous ne devons
pas nous ne pouvons pas nous n'avons pas
le droit une seule seconde de nous
laisser faire ces leçons de morale qui
consiste à nous faire croire que
défendre ses frontières
c'est manqué aux devoirs de générosité à
ceux qui nous parlent d'accueil et bien
demandons-leur de venir voir ce qu'ils
appellent vraiment l'accueil et qui
n'est rien d'autre que notre impuissance
qui devient tragédie pour ceux qui se
font piéger par cette fausse générosité
et je crois qu'il ya là un grand défi
européen
parce que oui l'ampleur du défi est
telle que nous n'avons pas le droit de
nous séparer entre pays européens
oui l'europe est plus nécessaire que
jamais disons leur disons le encore elle
est plus nécessaire que jamais pour
renforcer chacun de nos pays et non pas
pour nous laisser déposséder faire
daniel comme tu le disais par une sorte
de super état qui nous priverait de
notre expression démocratique
l'europe est nécessaire pour renforcer
nos pays face aux défis qu'ils
rencontrent et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons une double
frontières nous proposons de mettre
autour de l'europe une vraie stratégie
commune pour défendre ensemble les
frontières extérieures de l'europe et
laurent reviendra sur ce sujet si
capitale mais nous proposons
simultanément que défendre ensemble ces
frontières de l'europe permettent à
chacun de nos états de maîtriser
la politique migratoire et c'est ce qui
nous distingue aussi bien du
rassemblement national que de monsieur
macron le rassemblement national est
tellement idéologues tellement reposer à
l'europe qu'il a voté contre tout ce qui
pouvait permettre de renforcer l'europe
face aux défis migratoires
le rassemblement national a voté contre
l'établissement de contrôles
systématiques à l'entrée dans l'espace
schengen le rassemblement national a
voté contre parlement européen
le renforcement de frontex cette agence
qui lutte contre l'immigration illégale
par pure idéologie
j'ai été en grèce il ya quelques jours
j'ai rencontré les responsables de
frontex
personne ne peut penser sérieusement que
la grèce seul avec ses dizaines d'îles
pourra défendre sa frontière face aux
défis migratoires
oui il faut agir ensemble en europe mais
oui il faut agir ensemble en europe pour
définir une stratégie qui nous permette
non pas de gérer notre impuissance mais
d'y mettre fin j'irai notre impuissance
c'est ce que propose monsieur mâcon
peut-être avez-vous entendu il ya
quelques jours
madame belloubet chez bfm tv a dit on
n'arrêtera pas l'immigration
pour le dire autrement les flux
migratoires sont une fatalité
les gens vont et viennent 10 et l on ne
peut pas les arrêter est bien bien sûr
que si car une politique qui ne sait pas
maîtriser les frontières c'est une
politique qui prépare la dissolution de
toute réalité politique une politique
qui ne sait pas maîtriser les frontières
c'est celle qui nous condamne à nous
trouver déposséder de notre souveraineté
démocratique c'est celle qui voudrait
imposer des quotas de migrants comme le
propose monsieur macron aux pays
européens
monsieur mâcon propose de sortir de
l'espace schengen les pays d'europe qui
n'accepteront pas de prendre sur le sol
un quota de migrants eh bien nous nous
disons que ce qui compte c'est pas de
déplacer des gens d'un pays à l'autre de
manière arbitraire et administratives
c'est pas d'imposer aux sociétés une
immigration qu'elles ne peuvent plus
intégré ce qui compte c'est de
construire une europe qui renforce
chacun de nos pays qui renforce nos
démocraties et qui permettent à chacune
de nos démocraties décidé selon ses
capacités d'accueil et d'intégration qui
elle peut et qui elle veut accueillir ce
n'est pas à l'europe de décider qui doit
rentrer en france
et c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
parlons d'une double frontières défendre
ensemble les frontières extérieures de
l'europe défendre pour cela les
frontières de la france faire en sorte
que la france garde comme tous les pays
d'europe
la maîtrise de sa politique migratoire
voilà le défi qui est devant nous
et de ce point de vue là ne vous laissez
pas prendre monsieur macro on parle de
frontières mais rien n'a changé vraiment
rien n'a changé comme on le dit par chez
vous grand diseux petit faiseux monsieur
macro on parle de frontières mais jamais
l'europe
jamais l'europe n'a accueilli autant
jamais la france n'a accueilli autant
d'immigration légale
l'année dernière ces deux cent cinquante
mille titres de séjour qui ont été
délivrés c'est l'équivalent de la ville
de bordeaux qui rentrent en france
est-ce que nous pouvons accueillir une
ville de bordeaux en france en un an
la réponse que nous donnons est simple
la réponse est non et pour une raison
fondamentale le défi prioritaire pour
nous il est d'abord d'intégrer ceux qui
sont déjà ici et auxquels nous devons
faire partager le sens d'un héritage
commune d'un héritage commun le sens
d'une culture commune
voilà ce qui fait au fond l'un des
aspects les plus cruciaux de ce défi
européen
être capable de redire qui nous sommes
de partager qui nous sommes de
reconstruire ce lien commun jérôme
fourquet a publié un livre récemment qui
s'appelle l'archipel français dans ce
livre il montre à quel point la france
est en train de devenir un archipel de
communauté qui s'ignorent les unes des
autres qui s'éloignent les unes des
autres
et bien si nous ne voulons pas que la
france devienne un archipel qui prépare
les tensions et les crises de demain
il faut relever cet immense défi celui
qui consiste à refaire le lien qui nous
unit et ce lien précisément il se joue
aussi pour une grande part dans ce débat
européen car l'europe est ce lien
l'europe n'est pas seulement un projet
ça n'est pas seulement une construction
administrative ce ne sont pas seulement
des traités l'europe c'est d'abord un
héritage c'est d'abord une histoire
c'est une civilisation
l'europe c'est ce petit miracle discret
de la naissance de la raison dans la
grèce antique au vème siècle avant
jésus-christ ce miracle par lequel des
hommes et des femmes des ide qui ne se
contenteront plus d'une explication
mythique et qu'ils veulent comprendre le
monde et qu'ils veulent exercer leur
esprit critique pour mieux comprendre et
mieux connaître exercer leurs logos le
pouvoir logique
qui devient dialogos qui devient un
dialogue politique c'est la naissance de
la démocratie et de l'hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale jusqu'au conseil
municipal de la plus petite commune
nous vivons en enfants de ces grecs qui
ont inventé la délibération collective
par laquelle nous écrivons ensemble
notre avenir plutôt que de le subir
nous sommes les enfants de cette
histoire l'europe
l'europe c'est le sens de l'égalité
devant la loi devant la respublica
devant la chose de tout ce qui fait
l'esprit latin et qui s'étend dans tout
le monde latin par l'action de l' empire
romain c'est ce qui fait que petit à
petit un mur et le sens de l'état que
nous voyons si souvent bafoués
aujourd'hui et si nous souffrons de voir
ce sens de l'état bafoués c'est parce
que nous sommes d'une certaine manière
les héritiers des romains l'europe c'est
la tradition latine et c'est enfin
pourquoi ne pas le dire et pourquoi
avoir tant tardé à le dire pourquoi
s'être refusé nous mêmes à la nommer si
longtemps l'europe c'est évidemment
aussi cette histoire de la tradition
chrétienne d'une tradition
une tradition qui a fait mûrir pour le
monde entier progressivement
difficilement le sens de la dignité
humaine le sens de ce qu'est l'humain le
sens de ce que l'humain a une dignité
singulière qui fait que non l'humain ne
s'achète pas ne se vend pas ne se
marchande pas et qui fait
qu'effectivement l'europe
sonora d'agir contre la gpa contre la
gestation pour autrui à la
marchandisation du corps le sens de la
dignité humaine qui nous anime encore
aujourd'hui on a voulu nous faire croire
que nommer ses racines
on me le disait encore ce matin dans une
émission de radio
on a voulu nous faire croire que nommer
ses racines était une entorse à la
laïcité
mais d'où vient la laïcité sinon
précisément du mot latin qui désigne
dans l'église chrétienne
ceux qui ne sont pas des clercs la
laïcité vient du christianisme lui même
et oui bien sûr nous sommes laïque et
oui nous croyons à la séparation du
temporel et du spirituel
et oui jamais la politique ne doit se
résoudre à n'être qu'une opposition
communautariste entre des valeurs que
chaque communauté partage et qui
s'opposent les unes aux autres
oui nous cherchons ce qui nous est
commun et le sens de ce bien commun qui
nous lie mais oui tout cela vient d'une
histoire et ce commun a une histoire et
ce commun c'est la civilisation qui nous
attachent les uns aux autres
c'est l'europe et il faut retrouver le
sens de cette civilisation si nous
voulons relever tous les grands défis de
l'avenir
le premier ministre nous a opposé le
premier ministre nous a opposé que des
racines ne font pas un projet ceci me
rappelait le mot qu'avait employé
emmanuel macron dans un discours aux
bernardins dans lequel il disait vous
savez moi ce débat sur les racines de
l'europe ça ne m'intéresse pas ce qui
m'intéresse disait-il c'est là ce n est
pas les racines vous savez toujours
cette histoire que le nouveau monde est
forcément meilleur que l'ancien que pour
construire notre avenir il faudrait se
détacher du passé que pour se projeter
vers le futur il faudrait se détourner
de tout ce qui nous a fait ce matin
nathalie l'oiseau avec laquelle j'ai eu
le privilège de débattre à condition
qu'il n'y ait pas de caméra ni de radio
ce matin at-il et l'oiseau me disais je
ne veut pas d'une france en noir et
blanc quel mépris pour nos aînés quel
mépris pour ceux qui ont fait l'europe
dont nous héritons quel mépris pour
toutes ces grandes images en noir et
blanc qui sont effectivement ce qui
porte l'europe aujourd'hui quel mépris
pour qu'on le voit à travers la manière
dont ce gouvernement a traité les
retraités ceux auxquels nous devons
temps et bien moi je crois
qu'effectivement
je crois qu'effectivement on ne devrait
jamais opposé le nouveau à l'ancien et
je crois que ce qu'il ya de meilleur
dans le nouveau c'est toujours ce qui
est reçu de l'ancien et je crois que ce
qui fait la force qui nous pousse à
aller de l'avant c'est toujours ce qui
nous vient parfois du fonds des ans et
je crois assez vrai que toute personne
qui a un jour dans sa vie planter un
arbre c'est qu'on n'a aucune chance
d'avoir de la sève si on n'a pas d'abord
des racines
alors oui nous devons absolument pouvoir
rpt dire qui nous sommes parce que nous
avons devant vous une devant nous une
menace qui nous fait face et cette
menace un nom cette menace a un visage
cette menace c'est le communautarisme
qui gangrène notre société
cette menace c'est l'islamisme qui
menacent notre société et face à cette
menace il faut des réponses policières
et des réponses judiciaires c'est
absolument nécessaire
je m'étonne d'ailleurs que le mot
islamisme n'apparaissent pas une seule
fois dans le projet dans marche
face à cette menace il faut des réponses
d'une fermeté absolue mais à la fin nous
ne gagnerons la guerre contre
l'islamisme que si nous savons veut dire
qui nous sommes
parce que je le vois et je le dis comme
enseignant il y a aujourd'hui tant de
jeunes qui grandissent en france sans se
reconnaître de la france tant de jeunes
qui grandissent en europe sans se
reconnaître
héritier de cette europe si l'islam
radical prospère dans beaucoup de nos
quartiers c'est parce qu'il remplit un
vide que nous n'avons pas su habiter
si l'islam radical prospère c'est parce
que nous n'avons pas su donner à tant de
jeunes quelque chose à aimer nous
n'avons pas su leur donner la france a
aimé nous n'avons pas su leur donner
l'europe en héritage en disant cela je
n'excuse rien je ne pardonne rien de la
barbarie qui a fait tant de morts
mais je dis que si nous voulons être
intraitable devant cette barbarie
il nous faut d'abord offrir une autre
voie offrir un autre chemin et oui
disons le ensemble nous n'aurons pas
d'avenir si nous ne sommes pas capables
de nous reconnaître enfants de cet élan
qui nous précèdent qui nous dépasse
infiniment et qui nous relient tous
ensemble et qui fait notre force commune
on n'a pas besoin
on n'a pas besoin on n'avait pas besoin
d'être chrétien pour se sentir
profondément touchée en voyant brûler
notre dame de paris
et voilà ce qui fait le miracle d'une
civilisation partager ces pierres qui
date de près de dix siècles elles ont
quelque chose à nous dire
elle nous relient les uns aux autres
elles sont cet héritage commun qui fait
que nous ne sommes pas indifférents les
uns aux autres que nous ne sommes pas
des individus juxtaposés qui poursuivent
chacun leur intérêt que nous ne sommes
pas des communautés étrangères les unes
aux autres qui ne se reconnaissent rien
de commun oui nous sommes français
oui nous sommes européens et ceci fait
ce qui nous lie ce qui nous attache et
ce qui nous oblige les uns envers les
autres d'une manière définitive
alors oui il faut nous montrer à la
hauteur du moment dans lequel nous
sommes
soit l'europe changera soit l'europe
disparaîtra il nous faut refonder
l'europe pour pouvoir faire en sorte
qu'elle soit pour l'avenir encore
longtemps une force qui agissent dans le
monde et qui renforce nos pays plutôt
que d'être aujourd'hui cette cible qui
semble être passive devant toutes les
menaces et tous les défis de demain
oui il faut refonder l'europe et oui
nous croyons à l'europe
mais oui nous croyons que pour que
l'europe puisse peser il faut qu'elle
change en profondeur la manière dont
elle se construit oui nous croyons que
pour que la france puisse peser en
europe
il faut qu'elle soit représentée par
ceux qui portent la voix des français
d'une manière lucide est clair et c'est
la raison pour laquelle il est si
important que demain nous soyons le plus
nombreux possible à entrer au parlement
européen non pas pour la droite ou le
centre qui sont unis dans cette campagne
avec cpnt d'ailleurs je salue frédéric
nihous qui est ici avec nous non pas
non pas seulement non pas seulement cher
laurent pour notre famille politique
nous le devons bien sûr à notre famille
politique et à titre plus personnel je
te le doigt parce que tu as fait ce pari
et j'espère que dans quinze jours
j'aurais pu démontrer avec tous mes
colistiers que nous avons été à la
hauteur du paris que tu as fait mais
nous ne devons pas d'abord à notre
famille politique
nous le devons à notre pays nous le
devons à l'europe parce que nous sommes
à la croisée des chemins et il nous
reste quinze jours pour être à la
hauteur du défi quinze jours pendant les
années qui viendront je voudrais avec
tous mes colistiers être votre porte
voix au parlement européen mais pendant
les 15 jours qui viennent j'ai besoin de
vous j'ai besoin de votre voix il faut
que tous les jours vous puissiez si vous
êtes convaincu être aussi convaincant il
faut que vous puissiez parler à ceux qui
doutent parler à ceux qui se sont
éloignés de nous parler à ceux qui me
croient plus à la politique parler
peut-être aussi à ceux qui ne croient
plus à notre famille politique et leur
dire qu'il est temps d'y croire encore
parce que si vous êtes là ce soir c'est
que vous avez envie d'y croire encore et
oui vous avez raison d'y croire encore
dans 15 jours nous allons déjoué tous
les pronostics
dans 15 jours nous allons offrir à notre
pays à notre europe la victoire que nous
lui devons
ce sera votre victoire nous vous la
devons nous v'la devront merci
infiniment de ce que vous pourrez faire
pour refonder l'europe et pour rétablir
la france merci de votre confiance
merci de ce que vous allez faire merci
de cette victoire que vous aller
conquérir cette victoire c'est la vôtre
[Applaudissements]